hey this is Stevie TV here and I am
reviewing Wonder Woman which I saw last
night in IMAX 3d and first off the 3d
was a headache again like most 3d movies
and I got one or two arrow a shot at me
great waste of money off the top adding
the 3d but besides that I had lower
expectations for this movie originally
and the Ryan tomatoes gives it a 90% so
then your expectations go up and then I
was prepared to be disappointed and I
was I was not going in there one of
those guys was like hey did DC movie
they suck I'm just going to keep
painting on all them I wanted to do good
I want DC to come out with a good movie
and to me was disappointing again I
don't don't listen around tomatoes first
off it has the same issues a lot of the
other DC movies have where the fighting
is so much CGI and so much slow-mo just
overtop slow-mo we keep seeing women
tumbled around same shot so among them
like the Matrix Reloaded type of effects
and the fighting it's it's not letting
it flow it's not the hand-to-hand combat
that the mobile studio movie they're so
good at it's just slow-mo and then it
looks like a video game cutscene I feel
like I'm watching a video game cutscene
in most of these fights that was very
frustrating on its own the action part
of it other thing about it was I really
like Gothic at gal gadot as Wonder Woman
I think she was great I think she
perfectly played the Amazonian Queen and
I really liked the opening scene they
were in and the whole world they were in
and when she's getting trained and you
meet her mother and her mother's sister
and then it just left that world and she
went with Chris Pine and then it will
kind of well you know and I'm Chris Pine
was good in it but I guess the bias for
me is I'm not crazy about Chris Pine I'm
not crazy about I'm sick of its World
War one but I'm sick of the whole war
themes in general like the Germans being
the bad guys like we've seen it done it
felt like Captain America but I mean
that's the story how it goes but you
kind of got to push through it I wasn't
crazy about the sidekicks that meet up I
didn't think it was necessary to have a
whole team around Wonder Woman there was
like a Simon Pegg ripoff guy with a
weird haircut
didn't strike gold for me wasn't that
funny and then the translator guy wasn't
crazy about either and he had that joke
where he's like oh I'm aroused and
intimidated at the same time I was in a
full theatre totally bombed no one
laughed and it was when she was fighting
in the bar I was just like this guy's
not that funny sucks
and he wasn't cool either and same at
the Simon Pegg ripoff and that didn't
help so that was really annoying the
theme song with Wonder Woman that guitar
thing by Hans Zimmer not crazy about
he's better than that and I just keep
overdoing it a lot of overdone stuff and
then we got a cokehead villain who takes
miss coke and that's his superpower they
under used doctor poison she just kind
of made the gas and didn't really do
anything
and then the cokehead villain gets a
freaking sword the god killer sword down
his stomach but the doctor poison girl
she leaves she gets a free pass from one
woman so it was like come on what is
going on here and then the twist is
professor Luthor from Harry Potter is
the god Ares I make sure that shot of
him in the from the pot just in the
mother a hole or something it just was
weird seeing an actor trying to play
young and then hey I'm the bad guy
here's the twist and the corny shot
where he's leaving when he first meets
her into another keeps disappearing from
spot to spot it was kind of a cheat to
me I think was a cheat casting he was
only casted so like it was deceitful to
us because he's totally cast that that
guy could have diaries' oh look he's
Ares I didn't think that so that was
frustrating the live scene looks like
everything from Batman for Superman
battles or was just a fire pit and
raining is it just keeps repeating the
same type of imagery and seems Sipho
stories and the battle with her with
Ares was kind of cool but again it was
just CGI I could have seen in any video
game and again for me the stories my
vaccinator
I know the guys going through a lot not
a big fan again that's a red flag with
the story being by Zack Snyder the guy
he's not talented I'm sorry and he
ruining this franchise and once I saw
that Leo boy patty Jenkins directed well
you know get out did great as Wonder
Woman but story wasn't good and the CGI
was too much they got to change those
things and that's that
doesn't change here what it was better
than batting average Superman it was
better than Suicide Squad I'll give it
that was rather than Captain America to
me there wasn't a big fan of Captain
America and yeah I mean overall all
these movies I give a warm 210 I'm gonna
give this one a 6 almost a 5 I'll give
it a 6
it has its good moments I like the scene
with her when she's taking out her
shield and they're shooting the
machine-gun ahead that was cool
I like the flirtation between Chris Pine
in her there was a good chemistry didn't
need the snowfall corniness overdone oh
it's snowing there's no really basically
a lot of overdone stereotypical stuff
but it's a step in the right direction
for DC a small step but it's better than
the other one so that's the positive
thing I'm going to give it I'm going to
be doing a bunch of movies this summer
please follow SDB TV show on Twitter and
Instagram and please please subscribe I
work I respond to everybody comment
below if you disagree with me fight me
on it I will respond I want to hear the
hate I want to hear the love - it would
be great degree disagree please comment
or spawn - everybody please subscribe
and keep coming back